what were some of the tools that they
used to extract confessions from people
um that was a very hard
um
section to write about because I think
people here
we think about like what the police will
do to get a confession out of you it's
like okay they're gonna yell at you
they're going to rough you up
you know things like that it's like all
right I that's what we're used to as
like police brutality
so at a certain point they lower the
death penalty
for children
so I think it was 12 or 14 12 12.
and this became this was a big problem
for a Defenders of the Soviet Union
because this wasn't like hearsay this
was public and they're like
what are you what are you doing and one
of the reasons what they were doing is
if they would arrest people
they would have a death warrant for that
person's kid signed on the desk of the
interrogator
so you know your dad who I got to meet a
few weeks ago in Austin he's coming in
he knows he didn't do anything look I'll
just talk to them it'll be fine
and there's the death warrant for Chris
in his view signed like it's it's ready
to be delivered he'll confess to
anything I mean they they were having
Jews confessing and working for Hitler
um and there was another time when you
know they brought in someone who was an
old Bolshevik and the old Bolsheviks
were the people who fought the Czar they
were like the terrorists of their time
like people who were fought with Lenin
and they were hardened men you know the
[ __ ] could arrest them they had the
katarga system which uh presaged the um
the gulags they'd send with Siberia you
know middle of nowhere and these men did
that time for their political views and
they brought in one of them
and they called his I think it was his
mom uh or his mother-in-law and check
because she's watching his kids right
there and it's like oh are you kids okay
and they're like yeah and so they just
turned him he's like okay I'll sell
whatever you want you know so the when
you
again is something that is hard for us
to understand the West you know we are
all used to these movies where like you
know someone's brought in Tom Cruise is
tied to a chair and they're beating the
crap out of him he's like you know
spitting blood at them is just glaring
at them you bring in it's like we have
your kids
the calculus is and you know they're not
bluffing it's not like we have them but
like you know we don't really want to do
anything like they don't care and you
know they don't care
um and when that happens uh I don't
think any of us can understand what our
thought processes would be like what was
the conveyor
oh so the conveyor yeah there were so
many different techniques that they used
the conveyor it was called a conveyor
because you know they'd wake you up in
the middle of the night and someone
would be yelling at you for four hours
to confess and they'd make you write
down your whole life story and they rip
it up and write it again and then every
element oh so when this happened and
then when the guy who's interviewing
gets tired they just bring somebody else
like conveyor belt and you're up for
days at a time and as soon as there's
any discrepancy and was the movie you
and I went to see was it Amelie or was
it the southern movie oh why were you
lying about what movie you saw with
Chris and then it's like okay so now
they have now they have 10 this is ten
times you lied to us look at you're not
a trust it's very easy when someone
hasn't slept when every little slight
details being examined and the guy is
just a fresh one through the door and
the thing is the interrogators often
knew this guy hasn't done anything it
was just like he's got a job to do to
get you to sign that piece of paper uh
and the quicker we could do this the
quicker we get on with our our lives
does a study that was done on TSA agents
in in airports and what they wanted to
see was if given a outcome
will people retrofit reality in order to
be able to achieve it so the original
study was actually faces that were
either angry or happy and there was a
hundred images and you had to pick
between them angry happy happy angry
angry but after the first 50 images it
was only angry images
but people still kept on picking
happiness out of anger even though it's
quite obviously angry images because
they had a predetermined idea that this
is something that I should be searching
for and it was used to extrapolate that
to a question around TSA agents which is
that everybody has gone through the
scenario of there being nothing in their
bag and the security Guy saying we're
gonna have to open this up because some
things come up and you open it up and
he's like well there's nothing in here I
don't know what could have come up and
you don't know if it appeared on the
screen in a strange way or whatever but
there would be a question to be asked if
every single person arrived at the
airport with their bags perfectly packed
and no Contraband or any of the other
stuff in it
the TSA agents are still likely to pick
out issues within that because that is
what they're optimizing for that's the
function that they're optimizing for and
it's kind of the same with regards to
this oh yeah and then it's even worse
because if you think about it this way
what if that TSA agent is told
ten percent like one percent of the
populace or the people coming through
are potential terrorists like we know
through our research in our studies it's
one percent or point five percent
whatever small number and then you're as
the TSA agent is putting everyone
through
well if you put everyone through you're
either grossly incompetent or
maybe you're a potential terrorist
because they would love to work for the
TSA and now how you disprove that you're
a potential terrorist when the proof is
you're letting through Point you're
relating through literally every
potential terrorist right you haven't
clagged one single person so this must
be by Design one or two we can allow
that's you know negligent whatever every
single potential terrorist you let
through what's going on here Mr TSA
agent and that was part of the knife
that the the that was pointed to that
was hanging over their heads yeah there
was this sort of Damocles over pretty
much everybody what was the scalping
thing
yeah so they were very creative with
their tortures one of them was they
would tie a rope around someone's like
head I don't think this was done very
commonly and then they would have like a
stick attached to it and they would turn
it until just basically the skin off top
their head popped off
to me honestly the psychological
tortures were much more horrific because
we can all wrap our heads
thanks to Hollywood about like people
just being beaten in fingernails put off
and someone dislocates your shoulder
we've seen those movies you know with
the actors just getting the crap kicked
out of them and jaw broken and whatever
this you don't dare show
even in like a Silence of the Lamb's
context a movie where someone is brought
in
and their kid if that kid is being shown
hostage in a movie he's gonna get saved
right they're not going to show that you
sign the confession and they shoot the
kid anyway what was that General
Secretary stanislav kozia well that was
the hardest the hardest scene that was
the worst scene in the book
um I think Peter fector might be the
worst but this was the one where
um because he's also a very evil person
right stanislav kosior and he was head
of Ukraine
um they Stalin brought him to Moscow and
made him like uh like second in command
or gave him a major position like in
January I think of 38 and by May he's
arrested
and we don't know exactly what the
tortures were done to him but he was a
good Bolshevik strong you know Stalin
means Man of Steel they Pride themselves
in their ruthlessness and this is
something the interrogators had to do
it's like you're not going to feel
sentimental because this enemy of the
people is being tortured what kind of
person are you right like you're a
strong Soviet and you know they could
have kept him up all night they could
have thrown cold water who knows what
they pulled there was one um Russian
military Guy where they pulled out all
his teeth and then when he was pardoned
they gave him steel teeth and he was
instrumental in fighting the Nazis
during World War II and Stalin was like
oops sorry buddy
um
and the the thing with that scene is you
know they did something to him which was
not done to many other people uh as far
as my Research indicates and the
question is when the torturers reach
this kind of apex of torture is it
something that they always had in the
back of their minds we don't want to go
there but we know we can do it or is it
that this guy is a major name we have to
break him and we have to go into
Uncharted Territory were they letting
him think he's gonna outwit them or were
they like was he actually doing it was
he like going for you know like what's
his name um uh in gitmo uh Khalid what
he was the water board like 20 times or
some crazy number which no one had ever
done before they're like what this guy
is just like a beast right so at a
certain point they brought in his
teenage daughter and raped her in front
of him and then he broke and when you
read
you know even though the guy's a monster
he was complicit in the genocide of the
ukrainians and you know
just many torches on his name just to
kind of try to get into his head to be
like I don't care what these people are
going to do to me I'm innocent let me
talk to Stalin you know you know I know
how this works I I'm a proud Bolshevik
I've never would never betrayed the
people like spitting his blood in their
faces and then she comes in it's like
what's she doing here and he's like oh
you're innocent huh okay and then he
just saw and the thing is she killed
herself he got he outlived her she threw
herself in front of a train
um
and that's the kind of thing where when
people think of Oppression in the west
we think solitary confinement
cops not letting you sleep they're
beating the crap out of you they're
breaking your limbs
I think all of that is something that
would be excruciating no question for us
but when you're watching someone assault
your kids and know they're not going to
have any consequences for it
and like that's a wrap for you and it's
just like we don't know none of us in
the West
I think
under except under maybe ridiculous
circumstances
can appreciate that sense of
powerlessness
like even if someone is solitary
confinement uh shout out to Ross
Albrecht can still write letters to
people
receive information you know read a book
or something there's a little bit of uh
sovereignty sovereignty
and that which is just so
obscene in like almost a spiritual sense
is and the thing is our heads would
never go there like we we don't think in
terms like this and they were just very
the Soviets were very very
um
conniving and crafty in their
machinations
why was this extreme paranoia
overbearing police and Secret Service
involvement heavy use of cold Sellers
and hot sellers learning about that as
well was pretty [ __ ] awful 16 men
locked in a room where it was so small
that you couldn't even touch the ground
and the only thing worse than that was
the cold cellar which was basically
where you were left to freeze and this
super cold Siberian one they put you in
a no they put you in a pit like
basically like a like a basement and
they threw ice water on you naked
not good yeah why why do you do the cold
pledges that's true that's true maybe I
would have loved it they're a cool yeah
maybe I'd have loved it now it's cool
yeah just without the psychedelics and
Academy what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]